i made the mistake the other day
of wearing shorts because it was so hot
and
uh we were taping the show martin short
was the guest and he came out during
rehearsal
and i wish you had been there for this
sona because he is
one of the best insult comedians of all
time and we weren't even rolling tape or
anything
and he just told in two minutes 155
cruel jokes about my legs
um and me wearing uh shorts
and i mean i can't even remember most of
them because it was like a machine gun
and everyone the crew everybody
was howling and laughing at me no so
you're off to summer camp is that the
idea you know
well i'm gonna go to summer camp is that
well i hope you have a good day you know
and then now is that
those freckles they're benign are they
benign if they've been checked
and just wang wang oh man and
of course uh i maintain he's uh you know
funniest human being on this spinning
globe
he's hilarious but merciless and i
i remembered thinking it's the one time
i wore
shorts and i'm never wearing them again
oh okay
i don't care if it's so he hurt your
feelings a little bit no no i just it's
uh it's okay if he did no it just
like he found the vulnerability i must
completely
i must immediately seal the
vulnerability you know it's like when
they built the second
uh death star they didn't build the same
vulnerability again
did they matt yeah they did oh did they
oh yeah
okay it was worse no i'm sorry i mean
i should have yes sanded but yeah they
did
well yeah instead of just a thermal
exhaust port you could fly a full
couple of ships in there and get it this
time i didn't realize that
i can't remember it i thought it blew up
i can't remember why it blew up
but i get what you're saying i think
like one time i wore a sweater with a
collar on it and
you lit into me and i was like i'm never
wearing that again why did you have that
sweater
conan no i'm just what do you mean why
did he have that sweater
what he he just wanted why do you have
shorts well everyone has shorts
yeah but come on you know you're gonna
get made fun of
right it's true here's the thing you
make fun of yourself you're the one who
always says how like
pale your skin is how many freckles you
have how freakishly long your legs are i
had a memory
in camp i was in summer camp in freedom
new hampshire
the year was 1974 i think
and i'll never forget the food wasn't
great on this camping trip
and i remember they uh someone lopped
off a giant slice of spam and dropped it
into a frying pan
and i looked at it and then i looked at
my legs and realize
that they look exactly the same if you
want to know what my bare flesh looks
like
open any can of spam from like the 1940s
i've referenced spam for your flesh
before but i didn't realize there was an
actual
origin story yeah there was an origin
story i remember looking at it and then
looking at my leg and being really
bummed out
and then taking a bite out of my leg and
realizing it tastes very similar to spam
i'm not saying this to make fun of you
but i just thought that during the
summer especially when it's really hot
you have to be covered
like head to toe to wear a hat and like
long pants and like
uv protection shirts which i didn't even
know existed
until i started working for you and
bought them in bulk
i do have uv protection shirts stashed
everywhere
yeah the way an alcoholic hides bottles
i have uv protection a shirt stash so
you know when those any after school
movie or whatever when they depict
someone who's got a drinking problem
you know they yeah it's always someone
opens a closet or something and there's
all these empty vodka bottles that's
what it's like for me
but it's cut off sleeves it's just the
sleeve that comes up that you can buy
from some company
and they're called like gloody duties
and you pull them on
and they cover just your sleeves
and um and i've got all those
loose-fitting shirts that all those
companies make
and uh i've got spf 50 stashed
everywhere
i know it's not your fault it's not my
fault
god did it to me a cruel god
a very cruel god